if you want to see pretty much 100%
proof that sister Irene from the nun is
related to Lorraine Warren from the
conjuring then stick around to the end
of this video welcome back to things you
missed if you haven't already seen the
initial episode 34 things you missed in
the nun you'll want to watch that before
watching this video I mean I guess
there's no reason you have to watch them
in order but the reason that I say that
is I don't want a million people come in
and comment on this video telling me the
things that I missed that I already
covered in the other video one of the
first shots we see in the Abbey is
across with an infinity symbol in the
middle later on we see imagery of snakes
the symbol of Alec forming the same
symbol as well this may or may not be
related to something known as the
Leviathan cross which looks like this
and is sometimes used as a satanic
symbol during the opening scene when the
nuns are attacked by VALIC sister
Jessica mentions an important detail
that plays into the twist ending that's
the reason that sister Victoria
sacrifices herself and that the reason
that VALIC is able to escape the abbey
at the end using Frenchie as a vessel
you got to feel bad for Frenchie
he's just minding his own business finds
a body it probably gets demonetised for
it then literally gets demon Nitai z'd
aka possessed by a demon
alright clearly this pun isn't going
anywhere so I'm just gonna move on to
the next thing you missed so in the
other video I pointed out a few of the
Hidden Valley messages at the beginning
of the film and now I found a couple
more in the classroom where we first
meet sister Irene that there are some
letters in the wall the shape of the
chair right here creates the V then if
you go up from there you'll find the ala
K Ballack Ballack is also written way in
the background on the board
now that the nun is out on blu-ray I
have the power to pause and take a
closer look at all the words written in
father Burke's crossword puzzle here are
the ones that I found to be significant
anoint urn that's someone who applies a
ritualistic oil during a religious
ceremony in the nun I mean it's not oil
but sister Irene is protected by the
blood of the Holy Grail being smeared on
her forehead so I feel like there's
something there aimless that's a word
you could use to describe Frenchie at
the beginning of the story
what is it mr. wall and novice this one
describes sister Irene because she's
young and hasn't taken her vows sister
Irene helps him fill in the next word
deliveries and if you think about it
this may be more than an instance of her
holy crossword solving skills but also a
psychic vision because they end up going
to the delivery's room at the abbey the
ice house swirly drug deliveries father
Birkin sister Irene are asked to stay
overnight to talk to the other nuns in
the morning during the night the father
is lured out to the cemetery by the form
of a young boy he performed an exorcism
on years before named a Daniel if you
pause right at the moment that the
father shines his flashlight on Daniel
you'll notice that his eyes are glowing
white similar to how sister Irene looks
later on when she's having a vision
the father ends up being buried alive by
Valek but thanks to sister Irene's
abilities as a medium she's able to
rescue him and they find these books in
the coffin two of the books have snake
eyes on them which is notable because
valack is sometimes referred to as the
marquis of snakes
[Music]
and you'll later see plenty of snake
imagery when father Burke sits down to
study the books wait wait hold on roll
back on that for a second I think we can
use that clip in our next chill hop
video I can just imagine the title Lofa
chill ha for studying slash chilling
slash performing him exorcism I've
talked previously about how VALIC is a
character in the real world book the
Lesser Key of Solomon but in that book
he looks more like this and not really
like a nun the books found do have some
shadowy images of more traditional
looking demons so I wonder if those
pictures represent the true form of Alec
or maybe valach is just a big Brendon
Urie Fenn I don't know the other
document that the father studies is the
map of the abbey which is labeled cast a
Lewis ARP a Romanian for castle snake
the map also reveals the locations or
VALIC stalks the halls at night like
this tunnel where sister Irene is later
attacked
where does all this wind come from
anyway does VALIC just have the ability
to create wind I mean we see the same
thing in the conjuring too but it makes
more sense because there's a storm
outside anyway
when sister Irene finds sister Alana's
body in the chapel you can see that her
hands have been impaled painting the
grim picture that she's been crucified
during valence attack on the abbey
father Burke is investigating off on his
own and I noticed what I think is a
mistake it looks like they tried to
steal a shot from another scene or
something
the father is supposed to be by himself
at this point in the movie but who's
this also during the attack while sister
Irene is praying with the other nuns
there's a quick cutaway shot to this
statue and the baby has wings making it
look a lot more like Val X appearance in
the Lesser Key of Solomon after the
incident is over the wings are no longer
visible shortly after we get one more
look at father Burke's crossword puzzle
there are a couple pairs of opposites
execute and create obvious references to
Christ and dawn and dusk possibly
related to the fact that the nuns take a
vow of silence from dusk until dawn
he's also penned in the word reflective
you may remember that when Frenchie goes
to the pub in town they mentioned that
they cover all the mirrors after a death
so that the ghost won't see its
reflection sister Irene's first
encounter with the Baloch is through a
mirror in the chapel the last word that
I noticed on the crossword puzzle is
Juan the film that started at all the
conjuring and its sequel the conjuring
two are directed by James Wan alright
this last one is maybe the biggest thing
you missed I've ever done if I give out
a golden magnifying glass - the best
thing you missed it would be this thing
you missed there's been a theory
floating around about a possible
relation between sister Irene from the
nun and Lorraine Warren from the
conjuring both are mediums both have
intense visions of past present and
future
both have visions of and some kind of
tie to VALIC it seems reasonable to
suggest that this is a trait that can
run in the family
due to the fact that Lorraine's daughter
Judy also has visions of the nun the
Vatican tells father Burke to take
sister Irene with him on his journey
because she supposedly knows the area
however upon meeting her he finds out
that she does not know the area but
father Burke claims that the church must
have a reason for selecting her
every decision that Vatican makes is
with purpose I'm sure they have their
reasons for selecting you finally
there's the fact that the real life
actresses that play sister Irene and
Laraine Morin our sisters in real life
some have speculated that their sisters
in the movie some say that they're the
same person and sister Irene changes her
name later in life while some think that
their similarities are just coincidence
however in the nun
I think sister Irene's passport would
prove otherwise
Irene Palmer was born on March 2nd 1930
about three years after Lorraine's date
of birth Lorraine Warren's maiden name
is Moran so that might throw out the
theory that they're sisters
however Irene's place of birth is listed
as Bridgeport Connecticut which happens
to be exactly where Lorraine Morin was
born there may be further connections in
some of the deleted scenes of the nun so
make sure you subscribe to see zis world
to stay up to date on all the things he
missed ring the death bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]
[Applause]
you